I'm going to help you get going with your code. And, the first
thing you're going to need to do, is set up your development environment.
Actually, that's the second thing you need to do. The first thing
I'm going to have you do is download the code that you're going to
be using in this course. So to get the code, all you
have to do is click this Download ZIP button here in the
bottom right corner. When you do that, it's going to download the
ZIP of all the code in this repository to your computer. When you've
downloaded it, expand the ZIP and you'll see all the
folders for each of the lessons. Here's Lesson 2, Lesson
3, Lesson 4, and so on. Right now, go ahead
and download the ZIP for all the code for the course